There's a new report that Donald Trump has
abandoned his goal of forcing regime change
in Venezuela essentially because it's difficult
and complicated and he no longer has the patience
for it and he's effectively gotten bored and
moved on to other things, which sounds exactly
like what Donald Trump would do when something
gets difficult.
As many of you know, whether you agree with
me or you disagree with me, my position on
Venezuela has been clear for years.
The Chavez Maduro regimes have been absolutely
disastrous for Venezuela.
I want Maduro out for the benefit of the Venezuelan
people, but the United States cannot have
anything to do with it.
The United States cannot be the entity that
forces Maduro out.
chooses a Nicolas Maduro is replacement.
They can't be forced in or selected by the
United States.
Our involvement in Latin America over the
last 50 plus years has been nothing short
of catastrophic.
We back to coup in Honduras in 2009.
Our involvement in Argentina and Chile with
the repressive regimes of the 1970s through
which by the way, my parents live, uh, live
through, uh, through which my parents live.
I was born in Argentina in 1984 just a few
years after the military dictatorship fell.
Disastrous.
American involvement there in the 1980s backing
anticommunist contra forces in Nicaragua while
backing the right wing Salvadoran government,
disastrous involvement in Latin America.
And then more generally, I mean our entire
role and involvement with Cuba and the embargo
dating back for decades.
It's a very long list.
We do not want the United States involved
in Latin America and for awhile it really
seemed like getting involved in Venezuela
was a top priority for Donald Trump.
But, and this is good news, it seems that
Donald Trump has become frustrated and sort
of impatient with what's going on in Venezuela
and according to insiders, he's lost interest
in basically moved on to a new toy and that
new toy might be Iran.
It might be starting to do a bunch of rallies
for the 2020 reelection campaign that is now
getting going in, in, in earnest and in full
force.
This is good.
Okay.
This is another reminder that issues which
could really influence huge numbers of people's
lives are dependent on whether Donald Trump
is board, which is horribly a scary and disturbing
and embarrassing for the United States on
the national stage.
But this is a good thing and there's a very
good new report in the Washington Post, which
says that pushing regime change in Venezuela
really was looking attractive to Trump during
the winter.
Trump wanted a, when he kind of needed a win,
he had failed endlessly with China and the
trade policy and the bogus, a destructive
tariffs, the North Korea negotiations, negotiations
set number two with Kim Jong Un failed and
he was really looking for a win with Venezuela.
And then things sort of got stuck.
Maduro didn't leave Venezuela when it seemed
maybe he would, the Trump administration had
no clear path to his removal reports from
inside the White House are now that Donald
Trump simply lost patients and he lost interest.
Sort of like a little kid who fails three
times to beat a level in a video game and
decides to go play with his legos.
And there are counterpoints, uh, um, uh, to
these reports from some who say, well, Trump
hasn't abandoned Venezuela.
He's going to keep working on it.
It's just, there's kind of a break right now.
This is basically a case of who knew being
president could be so hard, but it's a very
good thing.
It is terrible that our president just gets
bored with difficult things and abandons them.
This is not a good trait for a president,
but in this particular case it's good that
Donald Trump got bored and frustrated with
regime change in Venezuela because we want
the United States staying as far from regime
change in Venezuela as possible.
Now, it could be argued that the Obamacare
repeal ultimately didn't happen for similar
reasons that Donald Trump got frustrated and
bored.
He wanted to do a repeal.
He campaigned on a repeal.
Republicans put together multiple ludicrous
bills that would have been terrible for tens
of millions of Americans.
They didn't pass.
Ultimately, even Republicans couldn't agree
on the right way to repeal Obamacare and then
Trump ended up just removing the individual
mandate for Obamacare and his tax reform plan
and effectively has moved on.
It seems that something similar has happened
in Venezuela and we just have to come to terms
with the reality that American policy, both
domestic and international, is ultimately
coming down to whether staff can keep Donald
Trump interested with pictures and charts
and compliments about how great he would look
if he was able to get something done.
We've truly never seen anything like this
before.
We've seen crooked presidents before.
We've seen presidents with all of the wrong
ideas.
Uh, reactionaries, neoliberal Warhawks, we've
seen all of that stuff before.
We've even seen ignorance in presidents before.
Remember George W. Bush, but we've never seen
anything like this in the fence that the degree
to which Donald Trump is bored with something
or frustrated with the fact that diplomacy
is a real thing.
Things don't just happen at the snap of a
fingers.
Maybe he's used to happening in the Trump
organization.
We've never had that boredom and frustration,
so directly determine what the legislative
priorities are and the geopolitical priorities
are of an entire administration.
It's truly something else.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram where we are asking you
questions about what Donald Trump shouldn't,
shouldn't be focusing on.
Yeah.
Uh, at David Pakman show is the David Pakman
show Instagram account.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
as well at David Dot. [inaudible] the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com